[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ساعه الاخباريه من
العربيه يقدموها لكم ابراهيم بدر
ونستهلوها بابرز العناوين
كيف تعلن فصل محطه نوويه عن شبكه الكهرباء
وانفجارات في مدن جنوب اوكرانيا
على وقع احتجاجات المتواصله في ايران
واشنطن تسعى لطرد طهران من مجلس حقوق
المراه وتتعهد بمحاسبه النظام
ردا على التجارب اصرخيه او الصاروخيه
لبيونج الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
تمددان مناوراتهما الجويه
قبل ايام من انطلاقها بيدن يحذر من ان رفض
نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه الكونجرس يمهد
الطريق للفوضى
اعلن شركه الطاقه
النوويه عن شبكه الكهرباء بعد قصف الروسي
دمر خطوط الضغط العالي بالمحطه واوضحت
شركه ان المحطه تعمل الان باستخدام مولدات
تعمل بالوقود مضيفه ان المحطه لديها وقود
يكفي لتشغيل المواليدات لمده 15 يوما فقط
افادت في كارت سبوتنيك الروسيه بدوي
انفجارات قويه في مدينه
السلطات المدينه الموليه لروسيا تفعيل
انظمه الدفاع الجوي مشيره الى عدم وجود
تهديد للمدينه في غضون ذلك افادت مصادر
اعلاميه اوكرانيه بوقوع انفجارات في مدن
خيرسون وميكو لايف وميكوبول جنوب البلاد
رئيس مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك
سيد رمضان بدايه نود ان نستوضح منك حقيقه
ما يحدث في محطه زبرجيا الانباء تشير الى
ان الروس قاموا بضرب خطوط الكهرباء التي
تزود المحطه الكهربائي اماما صحتهم في ذلك
وهم الذين يسيطرون عليها
حقيقه هذه المشكله انتقل كهربائيه
[موسيقى]
وهذا يعني ان روسيا تريد ان تحكم اوروبا
في الظلام
اكثر من هذه السياسه التي تنتهي
ثانيا هذا لن يعود على الدوله الاوكرانيه
باي فائده وكذلك في سياق تطبيق الدوله
يعني هذه المحطه عندما تكون خارج الخدمه
يجب ان تكون ضمن التغذيه محليه والروسه
الهدف الروسي هم تطبيق الاقتصاد الاوكراني
لكل ولذلك قصف يعني سبب التواصل مع هذه
المنشاه التابعه
للدوله الاخرانيه كذلك يكون في نفس السياق
يعني تدمير البنيه التحتيه الطاقويه
الالكترونيه كذلك اي خلل في التواصل
بالكهرباء سيخلق موزه خطيره ربما ستؤدي
الى انقطاعات للكهرباء في المدن وفي
اقاليم المجاوره لان المنظومه الطاقه
الاوكرانيه التي همم
منذ العهد السوريات هي كانت متكامله يعني
همم
قبل الهواء بانه هذه المحطه الضخمه همم
تحتاج الى التيار الكهربائي لانها هناك
حاجه لتبريد المواد الاشعاعيه الموجوده
فيها وبالتالي الروس سيتكفلون بهذا الامر
خصوصا يعني ان شركه الكهرباء التي كانت
تزود المحطه قالت لديهم يعني مخزون من
الطاقه يكفيهم لتشغيل مولدات لخمسه عشر
يوما
التقليديه
المنقوله كذلك تعمل من اجل شعل هذه
المنشاهذه الى الثوره التبريد يعني قضيه
فنيه تقنيه وشركه الروسيه لها تجربه يعني
اللي هي مؤسسه عريقه عبر العالم وتقوم
بانشاء محطات الذريه
ولكن هذا يعني ان هذا السياق هو السياق
السياسي
استراتيجي بضرب الاقتصاد يعني هذه
السياسيه
في حاله امان اظن يكون هناك اي اشعه تكون
مصدر قليل الا انها مصدر قلق من ناحيه
السياسيه والاقتصاديه التي تضرب سياده
اخرى يجب انه يؤكد ان روسيا تعمل كل شيء
من اجل تغيير البنيه التحتيه لتوليد
الطاقه لدى الدوله
اما ما يخص التبريد نعم هناك انشاءات
حراريه بالقرب
والروس يقومون بذلك لانه مهتمين لانهم
متواجدين على المنفى فوقفى في حال اي خلل
فان هذا الانشاء سينسيب كل الجيش وكل
الوحدات الروسيه التي تتواجد بالقرب من
هذه شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه التوضيحات من
كيف اوريج رمضان رئيس مركز الاوراسي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
وصلت السفير البريطانيه في موسكو الى مقر
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه بعد استدعائها
وذكرت وكاله ريانوفيسي بان ليست دعاء
يتعلق بتورط لندن في الهجوم الاوكراني على
صفه سبل بالقرم وخطيئه الانابيب نور الزين
واداره المقاطع مصوره تجمع عدد من الروس
خارج مقر وزاره الخارجيه مرددين هتافاتهم
بريطانيا بالارهاب
جدد مجلس الامن الروسي اتهام اوكرانيا
بتجهيز قنبله قذره بمشاركه دول غربيه وقال
سكرتير المجلس ان الغرب يريد محو العرقيه
الروسيه في شرق اوكرانيا محذره من ان
الوضع يندر بكارثه عالميه اذا لم يتم وقفه
كم اتهمه بتروشيف اوكرانيا بمواصله قصف
محطه زبرج النوويه رغم زياره وفدي وكاله
الطاقه الذريه
وصفات سيمون ملاحظات روسيا ومخوف بشان
الانشطه البيولوجيه في اوكرانيا بالمشروع
جاء ذلك بعد وقت قصير من فشل موسكو في
تمرين مشروع قرار في مجلس الامن بشان
مزاعملان الانشطه البيولوجيه فيكي وشدد
نائب مندوب الصين لدى الامم المتحده
جينشوان بان ملاحظات واسئله موسكو مشروع
وتستحق اجابات
قبل ذلك على النائب المندوب الروسي الدائم
لدى الامم المتحده لمترو بولياسكي بان
الوفود الغربيه خربت مفاوضات مشروع القرار
الروسي حول المختبرات البيولوجيه
الامريكيه في اوكرانيا
ابو اسماعيل
هذه هي العقليه الاستعماريه التي يحتاجنا
عليها ولا نتفاجا بها بغض النظر عن نتيجه
التصويت اليوم سنواصل الحفاظ على الاسئله
التي طرحناها على الولايات المتحده
واوكرانيا ومعرفه فيما اذا كانت الادله
التي رافقت شكوانا بحاجه الى توضيح سنواصل
العمل في اطار اتفاقيه الاسلحه الكيميائيه
مثل الجهود اللازمه لاثبات جميع الحقائق
المتعلقه بعدم امتثال الولايات المتحده
واوكرانيا لاحكام الاتفاقيه في سياق انشطه
المختبرات في اراضي اوكرانيا
من جانبها قالت ممثله الولايات المتحده
لدى الامم المتحده ليندا توماس جرين فيلد
ان الولايات المتحده صوتت ضد مشروع القرار
الروسي لانه يقوم على معلومات مضلمه
اهلا بك سيد دائرينا ربما القضايا التي
نود بحثها معك اليوم تتحدث عن تلوث سواء
كان نووي او بيالوج بدايه روسيا تعلم
تماما انا مشروع قرار من هذا النوع لن يمر
لان الولايات المتحده والدول الغربيه
الحنيفه لها سوف
تصوض ضد وبالتالي لماذا لجات روسيا الى
مجلس الامن لبحث هذه القضيه ماذا تسعى
لتحقيقه من خلال طرح هذا الموضوع
صباح الخير لانه
هذاك المحاوله تاتي في اطار
لحمله النفسيه ايضا وترويج معلومات حول
اوكرانيا كما تتصورها روسيا فتكرار نفس
المعلومات
لدى راي العامه الدولي
واذا ما نجحت مثلا روسيا مره اخرى في
اقناع الاخرين بالنسبه لمختبارات بيولوجيه
ف- همم في نفس الوقت في نفس الجلسه قد
نجحت برايي في تقديم معلومات حول هجوم
بحري على ميناء ستوفر باستخدام اتفاقيه
الحبوب
وباستخدام طائرات مسيره وانتم ذكرتم انه
سفيره بريطانيا قد استدعيتها الان في
الخارجيه الروسيه وهناك الا مقنعه كما
اعرفها لهذا الموضوع
وهذا كان له التداعيات على موضوع اتفاقيه
تصدير الحبوب ساتحدث معك عن هذا الموضوع
من شيق اخر
مجلس الامن الروسي جدد اليوم اتهام
اوكرانيا بالاستعداد لتجهيز قنبله قذره
بالتعاون مع الغرب ما مصلحه اوكرانيا
بانتاج هكذا نوع من القنابل لو تم اطلاق
هذه القنبله القذره سيتم تلويث كامل محصول
اوكرانيا من الحبوب وهذا يعني بانه لن يتم
تصدير حبه قمح واحده وبالتالي اليس هناك
تضارب في المصالح
ولكن في نفس الوقت دول الغرب تتهم روسيا
بامكانيه اللجوء للاسلحه النوويه وهي ايضا
لديها قوات حيا هناك ولكن هذه المساله
حتتكرر من حين لحين
فللاسف اللجوء الاسلحه النوويه ممكن ان
يتم قبل كل الاطراف المتنازعه رغم انه لا
يوجد موسكو في وقت الاخير اصبح
تغيرت روسيا الان تتهم اوكرانيا في هذا
الشيء همم
وبيان الخارجيه الروسيه مساء امس كان همم
ملفت للنظر الخارجيه الروسيه بعد اعضاء
مجلس الامن الدائمين
للعمل المشترك لتجنب هذا السيناري
والكارثه هذا يعني انه هذه اعواد كانت
مواجهه ايضا
لفرنسا وبريطانيا وامريكا وليس فقط للصين
سؤال اخير انه في ظل هذا التوتر الشديد
الذي تشهده كل من روسيا واوكرانيا والغرب
لماذا لا يتم طرح
مساله التفاوض من جديد وايجاد حل لكي لا
تذهب الامور الى ما تحمل عقبه
بالعكس هذه المساله يتم طرحها ولكن
هي مدى مدى يعكس جديه همم الاطراف في هذا
الشيء همم وهذيك المساله تطرح ما قبل
روسيا تقول انه مستعد ان تتفاوض مع بعيده
انها على مستوى رئيس بوتن همم
هي تقول انه مستعد لاجراء بعد الاتصالات
ولكن في نفس الوقت همم اسمع من خبراء
عسكريين كثيرين في روسيا انهم ما زالوا
يحلمون ببناء على شاطئ البحر الاسود وهذا
يعني لا ما زاله ان يشعرون للتقدم على
الارض
شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا موسكو المختصر
في الشؤون السياسيه والاستراتيجيه الروسيه
الينا سبونينا
على المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه نت
برايس انا واشنطن تعتزم استخدام جميع
الوسائل المتاحه لوقف توريد الاسلحه من
كوريا الشماليه الى روسيا
اعلنت فكره التعاون العسكري الامريكيه ان
الاداره الامريكيه وافقت على بيع فنلندا
400 صاروخ موجه للانظمه الصاروخيه لتجديد
الترسانات الوطنيه وتعزيز قدرات الدفاع
جاء ذلك في بيان للوكاله واكد انا فيلندا
تعتزم استخدام هذه المنتجات الدفاعيه
لتجديد تراسنتها وتعزيز قدرات الدفاع
البري والجوي للجناح الشمالي اوروبا مؤكده
على ان تجديد اترسانات له اهميه بالغه
للدفاع وقدره الردع الفلنديه فيما يتعلق
بالوضع الصعب في القطاع الامني في اوروبا
مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
وزراء خارجيه مجموعه السبع يبحثون في
المانيا الحرب في اوكرانيا و احتجاجات
ايران
يزور الامين العام لحلف الناتو ينسلتنبر
تركيا اليوم
السويد وفنلندا الى حلف الاطلسي
قال انه يرحب بعمل السويد وتركيا معا
لتنفيذ المذكره المشتركه في اشاره الى
اعلان اردوغان عن اجتماع المحتمل مع رئيس
الوزراء السويدي الجديد اولف
كريستينا
دوله اعضاء فنيه
يبحث اليوم وزراء خارجيه مجموعات الدول
السبع الكبرى سبل تنسيق الدعم لاوكرانيا
خلال اجتماعهم في مدينه نصر المانيا وذلك
بعد الهجمات الروسيه الاخيره على البنى
التحتيه للطاقه ومن مقرر ان يلتقي وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
ونظرائه في مجموعه السبع الحديثه ايضا عن
موضوعات اخرى مثل الدور الصيني المتزايد
والاحتجاجات في ايران
على المبعوث الامريكي لايران روبرت مالي
في مقابله مع العربيه الى ايران تنتهي
حقوق النساء ولا يجب ان تكون عضوا في لجنه
حقوق المراه مضيفا انه لا يمكن لايران
اخفاء ممارساتها وسيتم محاسبتها على
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان وان الولايات
المتحده تعمل مع شركائها لطردها من لجنه
حقوق المراه ما لي اشهر ايضا الى ان ايران
تقفوا في الحرب الى جانب روسيا وانه سيتم
فرض عقوبات على اي جهه تصدر المسيرات
الايرانيه الى روسيا اما في شان نووي فقال
مال للعربيه ان عدم امتلاك ايران اسلحه
نوويه يصب في مصلحه امريكا القوميه
والمنطقه
وهو بشان مقتل الفتاه الايرانيه مهسا امين
اعتبر المبعوثه الامريكي الخاص في ايران
روبرت مالي في لقائهم على العربيه انا
محاوله الضغط لطرد ايران من لجنه الامم
المتحده المعنيه بوضع المراه لم يحدث للتو
وكان يتم التحضير له مع العديد من الشركاء
والفاعلين في مجال حقوق الانسان
اليوم نائبه الرئيس اصدرت اعلان رسميا
وسيكون هذا هو هدفنا لكن كما تعلمين ان
الشطاء الايرانيون وغيرهم من الفاعلين في
مجال حقوق الانسان كنا ندفع جميعا لتحقيق
هذا الامر
وفي حديث العربيه عن المتحدث باسم البيت
الابيض كارين جون بيير او بتحدث اعلانات
انا اداره الرئيس فايدر نشدت الحكومه
الايرانيه ومارست الضغوط على مدى الاسابيع
العديده الماضيه للتاكد من محاسبه طهران
بسبب الاجراءات الرهيبه التي اتخذتها ضد
المتظاهرين
دخول
رانيا
[موسيقى]
بحقوق الانسان في ايران
عن 298
الدجاجات على مقتل الشابه محسن امينه
وقدرت رانا ان اكثر من 14 الف شخص تم
اعتقالهم خلال الاحتجاجات وما زالت هويه
الكثيرين منهم غير معروفه
هذا رغم قمع نظام الايراني تتواصل
احتجاجات في مناطق مختلفه وخرجت تظاهرات
ليليه في منطقه تشكر بالعاصمه طهران فيما
اطلقت قوه الامن النار على المحتاجين
وهددت السكان عبر مكبرات الصوت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والمزيد من البحث حول هذا الموضوع ينضم
الينا هنا في الاستوديو الباحث في شان
الايراني مسعود الفكر اهلا بك سيد مسعود
بدايه اشرنا الى تقديرات حول ارقام
القتلى والمصابين في ايران تبلغ نحوه 300
ضحيه سقطت هل هناك اعداد اخرى خصوصا ان
الارقام تضاربت منذ بدايه هذه الاحتجاجات
قبل نحو 50 يوما تاره ترتفع وتاره تنخفض
هل هناك همم ارقام حقيقيه يمكن الرجوع
اليها
السلطات الايرانيه لا
تنشر
[موسيقى]
ارقام او احصائيات الدقيقه
وتتجنب الحديث حول ذلك لانه عندما تعترف
بشقوط ضحايا تحترق بالجريمه المرتكبه بحق
المحتجين الا انها تذكر في تقاريرها فقط
بان هناك 35 من عناصر الامن وقوات البسيج
قتلوا خلال الاحتجاجات لو قابلنا بذلك هذا
يعني عدد الذين سقطوا من بين المحتجين يجب
ان يكون عشره اضعاف عدد وارقام عناصر
الامن الذين مسلحين بالاسلحه
بالحراوات
وبمختلف في همم لذا هذا الامر باعتقادي
ينعكس بشكل يظهر عدد همم
الذين همم في واقع الام سقطوا خلال هذه
الاحتجاجات لذا الارقام قد تلامس الحقيقه
الى حد ما ااا على ضوء عدم وجود نعم
بالنسبه للمعتقلين 14 الف هذا رقم كبير
دون الكشف عن هوياتهم
تداعيات هذا الامر داخل مجتمع الايراني
الذي يطالب بالكشف عن هويه اسباب مقتل
كثير من المتظاهرين التي لم تعلم وايضا
الى اين ذهب هؤلاء الذين لم تتم محاكمتهم
العدد لو حسبنا الايام ايام المظاهرات
اليوم نحن حوالي
47 يوم من الاحتجاج
الاحتجاج في 150 مدينه ايرانيه
في امم عشرات الجامعات الايرانيه مستمره
لذا الرقم ليس مبالغ فيه والبعض يعتقد
بانه الارقام قد وصلت الى نحو 20,000 هذا
ما يتحدث البعض ولكن لو قابلنا ب 14.000
هناك ازمه حقيقيه بالنسبه همم للنظام
الايراني لم يستطيع اخماد الاحتجاجات لذا
ارتفع عدد المحتجين
بموازاه ذلك ارتفاع عدد المنتقلين هذا
الرقم يثبت بان الاحتجاجات كانت واسعه
ومنتشره في مختلف واعود منك ان تستعرض لنا
الان في هذا اليوم السابع والاربعين خارطه
الاحتجاجات اين تركزت وكيف تم التعامل
معها
ليله البارحه كانت الاحتجاجات في اربع مدن
كبيره كانت في في العاصمه طهران
ولم تكن الاحتياجات من
النوافذ وسطوح البيوت او من خلال الشرفات
لا كانت في داخل الشارع في مركز العاصمه
في منطقه اسمها سلسبيل منطقه سلسبيل تعتبر
جزء من تركيب الطهران القديمه ااه ان تخرج
خلال الليل مظاهرات في الشارع في هذه
المنطقه هذا الامر له رمزيه المظاهرات في
قلب العاصمه الايرانيه يعني وكانت
المظاهرات في تبريج اكبر مدينه تركيه
اجاريه في ايران ليله البارحه ايضا
مظاهرات كانت واسعه في مدينه تبري وكانت
شعراء طبعا باللغه التركيه
وسلندج عاصمه كردستان ايران ايضا كانت
فيها احتجاجات
واصفهان احدى كبريات المدن الايرانيه
والمدينه التاريخيه التي المدينه التي خرج
كثير من مسؤولين النظام من هذه المدينه من
رجال الدين الى عسكريين الى امنيين
كثير منهم خرجوا من اصفهان اصفهان ليله
البارحه شهدت مظاهرات حاشده همم في همم
قلب المدينه فاضطرت السلطات الايرانيه الى
قطع الكهرباء في تلك النقطه حتى يضطر ال-
ال- المحتجون العوده الى البيوت الا انهم
استمر في الاحتجاج خلال ساعه الظلام فقط
انترنت
السلطات لقطع الانترنت لمنع المحتاجين من
بس الصور هذه الاحتجاجات الانترنت
ضعيف للغايه لدى معظم الصور التي تاتي من
الداخل والمقاطع الفيديو قصيره جدا لانه
فتره تحميلها بسبب البطن لذا الانترنت انت
بالنسبه للمحتجين تجاوزوا قطع او عدم قطع
الانترنت في ايران
ضيفنا في الاستوديو
هذه النشره مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض
الفاصل
ترقوا في اسرائيل قبيله نتائج اعلاني
نتائج انتخابات الكنيست
على وضع احتجاجات المتوسطه في ايران
واشنطن تسعى لطرد طهران من مجلس حقوق
المراه وتتعهدوا بمحاسبه النظام
ردا على التجارب الصاروخيه
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه تمديدان
منوراتهما الجويه
الانتخابات النصفيه
اهلا بكم من جديد تعلن اللجنه المركزيه
للانتخابات في اسرائيل نتائج نهائيه
للانتخابات الكنيست اليوم فقد اظهرت نتائج
الاوليه بعد فرز 97% من اصوات المخترعين
فوز معسكر رئيس الوزراء السابق بني من
نتناهب بخمسه وستين مقعدا من اصلي 120 هي
مجموع مقاعد الكنيسه يحتاج الى 61 مقعدا
على الاقل تشكيلي حكومه تعيده الى مكتب
رئاسه الوزراء الذي غادره العام الماضي
وكانت لجنه الانتخابات المركزيه ذكرت ان
71.3% من الناخبين شاركوا في التصوير
وتنضم الينا من القدس مراسله العربيه لا
نقل عاصي اهلا بك لانا اذا تاخر اعلان
نتائج النهائيه حتى اليوم هل هناك جديد
فيما يتعلق
بنسب الفرز الذي وصلنا لها وموعد اعلان
نتائج
اربع سنوات وراينا اقبال كبير من قبل
الشارع الاسرائيلي فهذه الانتخابات حصلت
على يعني النسبه الاعلى من المشاركه منذ
عام 1999 اما بالنسبه للاصوات تم فرز حتى
الان
97% من الاصوات وهناك حوالي 600 او 5,000
من الاصوات المغلف مزدوج تحتوي على اصوات
المشاركين من سجناء دبلوماسيين وايضا
الجنود حتى اللحظه لم يتم الاعلان عن فرز
هذه الاصوات ولكن نحن نتحدث عن العنوان
الامبراز منذ الامس وهو عوده نتنياهو وفوز
نتنياهو حتى الان يعني هناك
بغض النظر عن ما تتضمنه لن تغير نتيجه همم
سباق وان نتنياهو حسم الامر
الاعداد ربما لا لن تغير لان نتنياهو حتى
الان حصل على 65 مقعد ونحن نعلم انه يحتاج
61 مقعدا حتى يستطيع تشكيل الحكومه فحسب
ما قال هذا انتصار كبير ل اا نتانيا وهو
فعليا انتصار لانه حصل على 65
من قاعده وبذلك هو يستطيع تشكيل حكومه
يمنيه وسيقوم همم تشكيلها على ما يبدو لكن
النتائج النهائيه ستظهر اليوم وربما
بالامس حسب التوقعات شكرا جزيلا همم
كنت معنا مباشره من القدس
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه عن مقتل فلسطيني
برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي في بلده شمال غربي
القدس التي ذلك بعد اقتحام قوات كبيره من
الجيش الاسرائيلي للبلده واندلاعه مواجهات
مع شبان فلسطينيين بحسب مصادر فلسطينيه
عبر رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه المنتهيه
ولايتها في ليبيا عبد الحميد بيبي عن
تفاؤله بعد استكمال المجلس الاعلى للدوله
في ليبيا التصويت على القاعده الدستوريه
واحالتها للجان المختصه لوضع الضبط
النهائي لها واضافت بيبي بانه مازال يطالب
بان تمضي باقي الاجراءات في اسرع وقت ممكن
للخروج بقاعده دستوريه سليمه تكون محله
قبول عند كل الليبيه مشددا على انه ما زال
يطالب ايضا بانفه كل الاطراف التزاماتها
تجاه العمليه الانتخابيه باكد انه ليس
امام الليبيين الانتخابات لانهاء المراحل
الانتقاليه
في السودان تتواصل ردود الافعال حول قرار
لجنه الاستئناف بالغاء حل النقابات والذي
قضى بعوده نقابه المحامين محسوبه على
النظام القديم الشرطه السودانيه اغلقت
الشوارع المؤديه الى مقر نقابه المحامين
في الخرطوم لمنع حدوث اشتباكات بين اعضاء
اللجنه التيسيريه للمحامين ونقابه
المحامين المحسوبه على النظام السابق
هتاف وهتاف مضاد هرج وسباب وفوضى
مكانه مقر نقابه المحامين السودانيين
وزمانه عقب صدور قرار الغاء حل للنقابه ما
يعني عوده نقابه ما قبل الثوره اما اسبابه
مع اعتبره قانونيون عوده لمؤسسات النظام
القديم
عن الاطار والاذن القانونيه رغم ان هذه
القرارات جاءت قرارات سياسيه ليس لها
علاقه بالقانون وليس لها علاقه
بالعداله باي حال من الاحوال
القضيه من جانب نقابه النظام السابق اكمن
في عدم شرعيه اللجنه التي صاغت مشروع
الدستور الانتقالي وفتحت الباب لتدخلت
خارجيه
السودان وشعبه
السوري
الغاء حل النقابات على احكام قانونيه ولا
يمكن التعامل معه بمعايير سياسيه هكذا
يقول البعض ربما هذا يجعل كل العمليه
السياسيه التي تمت خلال الفتره الماضيه
لاشرف قليل الماضيه كانما طعت هباء منثوره
ولم تعد موجوده ولا يمكن ان يعول عليها
وهذا طبعا الوضع قانوني من الص تعامل معه
باي معيار سياسي يعني لابد التعاون يكون
قانوني ولا اعتقد ان التعامل القانوني هنا
قد استطيع همم الغاء الترتيبات التي تمت
لانها ترتيبات من الزاويه القانونيه
مصعوبه في مكانها
ما حدث في مقر نقابه المحامين على خلفيه
قرار الغاء حل النقابات يفتح الباب واسعا
امام جدل سياسيا وقانوني وبعضهم ذهب الى
ان في ذلك عوده لواجهات النظام السابق
وردتا عن مبادئ الثوره في ما مضى بعض
الاخر الى وضع تلك القرارات في الاطار
القانوني بعيدا عن السياسه محمد عثمان
العربيه الخرطوم
حضر التالو الولايات المتحده جميع الدول
على تعزيز العقوبات المفروضه على كوريا
الشماليه باعتباري انها انتهت قرارات مجلس
الامن الدولي باطلاقها صاروخا بارسيا
عابرا للقارات واضافه المتحدثه باسم مجلس
الامن القومي بان الرئيس جو بايدن وفريقه
للامن القومي يعملون على تقييم الوضع
بالتنسيق الوثيقي مع الحلفاء المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه قال ان اطلاق
بيونغيانغ لصواريخ البالسيه يظهروا
تهديدها لجيرانها والمنطقه والسلام والامن
الدوليين ونظام منع انتشار الاسلحه
النوويه العالميه في اثناء اتفقت
واشنطنبول على تمديد التدريبات الجويه
المشتركه بعد تجارب كوريا الشماليه
الصاروخيه
قبل ذلك دعت الحكومه اليابانيه سكان بعض
المقاطعهات الى الاحتماء او الالتزام
المنازل بعد اطلاق كوريا الشماليه
لصاروخها الباسي وقالت الحكومه في وقت
لاحق ان الصاروخ حلق بالفعل فوق الاراضي
اليابانيه متجها نحو المحيط الهادي الى
ذلك افادت مصادر يابانيه بان طوكيو تدرس
نشر صواريخ فرط صوتيه لتعزيز الردى ضد
تهديدات كوريا الشماليه
انضم الينا من طوكيو الصحفي خلدون الازهري
اهلا بك سيد خلدون بدايه
حقيقه موقف اليابان الان بدا ياخذ شكلا
تصاعديا او تصاعديا فيما تعلق بالتجارب
الصاروخيه الكوريه الشماليه الى اي مدى
سيطلق هذا الموضوع سباق تسلح في المنطقه
خصوصا من قبل اليابان التي تحلق هذه
الصواريخ او الصواريخ في اجوائها
في الواقع اولا هذا الصاروخ لما يحلق فوق
اجواء اليابان حسب اعلنت وزاره الدفاع في
تصحيح لبيانها الاسبق هذا الصباح وقالت
انه سقط حتى خارج المياه الاقليميه
اليابانيه صاروخ هو كما نعرف هاوسون 17
الكوري الشمالي الذي نجح في المرحله
الاولى ونفك الجسم عن الراس الحربي ولكن
بعد ذلك همم بدا التحرك راس الحربي بشكل
عشوائي وهو في البحر بما يعتبره
اليابانيون فشلا لهذه التجربه الصاروخيه
اليابان طبعا تردد بتعزيز بتراسادتها
الصاروخيه في سباق تسلح واضح في شرق اسيا
بين هذه الدول التي تفتقل الى الحل
الدبلوماسيه او الحوار فقط نسمع عن
استعراض وتراشق للتهديدات والتمديدات
العسكريه اليابان تعتمد على الولايات
المتحده للدفاع عن نفسها ولكنها كما ذكرت
من تامل بتطوير صواريخ منظومه صواريخ فرض
صوتيه بحلول عام 2030
سنوات لكن نحن نشهد كل ثمانيه ايام تجارب
سواء كانت مدفعيه او صاروخيه من قبل كوريا
الشماليه ما الذي تريده كوريا الشماليه من
خلال اجراء هذه التجارب هل تسعى الى
التطوير ثلاث رسانتها وقدراتها الصاروخيه
ام انها تريد ايثار رساله الى دول المنطقه
المحيطه والولايات المتحده
هي تريد تحقيق هذين الهدفين تماما بالضبط
اولا تسعى لتطوير ترسانتها الصاروخيه وكما
نعرف نجحت هذا اليوم في تطوير هذا الصاروخ
المحسن هاوسون 17 الذي وصل ارتفاع يقارب
2000 كيلومتر ومسافه 750 كلم وايضا نجح في
المرحله الثانيه الى حد ما نذكر ان
صاروخانق في مارس الماضي فشل حتى في
انطلاق في المرحله الاولى وسقط على بعد
على ارتفاع 20 كيلومتر فقط من اطلاقه اذن
هذه التجارب الصاروخيه الكوريه الشماليه
تهدف الى تحسين نوعيه صواريخ والمنظومه
وخاصه مسار الصاروخ وتحديد الهدف واصابته
بدقه هذا تفتقد اليه كوريا الشماليه
والاسيه ما اذا كان محملا براسا حربيه على
الاقل سياسيا تهدف كوريا الشماليه ايضا
الى اظهار الحلفاء الثلاثه امريكا
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه انها لا تبالي
بكل هذه التمديدات العقوبات الدوليه وتريد
الاعتراف بها كدوله نوويه او ايضا تخفيف
العقوبات المفروضه عليها بشكل تدريجي
مقابل هي ان ايضا همم تتخلى عن همم
تجاربها بشكل تدريجي يعني خطوه مقابل خطوه
لكن
نستفيد من وجودك في العاصمه اليابانيه
طوكيو برايك المواطن الياباني هل يهتم
كثيرا بهذا الموضوع خصوصا ان اليوم شاهدنا
دعوات من السلطات للمواطنين للبقاء في
منازلهم او بالملاجئ بعد اطلاق هذه
التجربه صاروخيه
في الحقيقه اصيب بالراب سكان محافظات ثلاث
في شمال الغربيه اليابان بسبب اطلاق
التحذيرات وهي من صاروخ وكانت وزاره
الدفاع اعلنت انه عبر الاجواء اليابانيه
وهناك تقارير بانهبط او سقط فوق اليابان
هذا اثار رعبا كبيرا في اليابان وحتى ان
قطارات القطارات سريعه توقفت مؤقتا اذا
هذا الرعب في الداخل ياباني يساعد الحكومه
نوعا ما على المضيق قدماء في سياستها
العسكريه بتطوير ترسانتها في كافه الانواع
الاساس وجود تهديد صيني قريش شمالي وايضا
روسي دائما في اليابان ضد اليابان اذا
هناك نوع من التغيير في السياسه اليابانيه
العسكريه بسبب هذه الصواريخ وهذا كما نعرف
في غياب اي محاوله للحوار او حل المشكله
بالوسائل السلميه التقليديه وعن طريق
التفاوض شكرا على وجودك معنا صحفي خلدون
الازهري كنت معنا مباشره من طوكيو
الان الى اخبار الاعمال مع سميره نادين
تفضل يا نادين
[موسيقى]
من جديد
باسواق المنطقه لكل اليوم تكتسب اللون
الاحمر من بعد قرار الفيدرالي برفع
الفائده بثلاث ارباع النقطه المئويه
وتغيير
بالتوجهات المستقبليه التوقعات السابقه
كانت لرفع حد بوتيره الفائده ولكن لفتره
قريبه ومن ثم التحول من التجديد النقدي
الى التليين اذا حصل ركود اقتصاده جرن
باول غير هذه توقعات يوم امس
بالاشاره الى انه اسعار الفائده ستستمر
بالارتفاع لفتره اطول ولو بوتيره اقل يعني
نسبه الرفاع ستكون اقل انما الفائده
النهائيه التي نسبه الفائده النهائيه التي
سيصل اليها من بعد الانتهاء من دوره
التشديد ستكون اعلى من ما يتوقعه السوق
وبالتالي حصل سالف على الاسواق الامريكيه
كما نرى خلفي تراجعات حاده جدا على الناسك
باكثر من ثلاثه% انسحبت على تداولات اسواق
المنطقه اليوم خلينا نلقى نظره على عوائد
سندات الخزانه الامريكيه التي ارتفعت يوم
امس من بعد قرار الفدرالي عائد السنتين
يتداول قرب الاربعه فاصل عقبال 100 الان
4.67 وعائد ال 10 سنوات ارتفع الى
4.14% هذه الاسواق بالمنطقه اليوم فاذن
كلها على نزول همم السعوديه تتراجع باحد
اكثر من غيرها تراجعات بواحد بالمئه عذرا
عنده بين نصف نقطه مئويه الكويت وقطر ايضا
على تراجع نبدا من دبي اليوم حيث سالك
مرتفعه هي من الادراجات الجديده النسبيا
سوق دبي ادرجت هذا العام اتيكم على ثبات
ولكن اضيع ايضا ادرجت هذا العام وعلى
تراجع اليوم واعمار على تراجع بالقطاع
المصري في عنا دبي الاسلامي واميره على
نزول اشاره الى ان البنوك المركزيه
الخليجيه لاحقه بخطوه الفدرالي ما عدا
الكويتيه يعني السعوديه والامارات رفعت
الفائده بثلاث ارباع النقطه المئويه هذه
الاسهم بالسعوديه ابو ظبي اليوم عذرا ابو
ظبي للموانئ خلصت المكاسب الصباحيه قامت
توافق مجلس الاداره بالاستحواذ على شركه
مقرها دبي بقيمه 800 مليون دولار عم يشترو
80% منها وهذه كيكه هي قلوب الفيدر شوبينج
مقر بدبي ابو ظبي للموانئ قلصات المكاسب
ولكن فرتك قلوب تبقى مرتفعه بتلاته بالمئه
من بعد ما اعلنت عن نموه 111% بارباح ربع
الثالث الى 291 مليون دولار هي تعمل بقطاع
الاسمده وارتفعت الايرادات الى مليار و320
مليون دولار اتت اعلى من توقعات المحللين
لمليار ربع دولار فاذا فرتي جلوب على
ارتفاع بثلاثه بالمئه اليوم المصاريف ضاغط
على سوق ابو ظبي متراجعه ننتقل الى الكويت
لنرى الصوره بالسوق الكويتيه فاذن
بالاجمال الصوره نزوليه بالكويت عنها زين
على تراجع البورصه شمال الزهور على ثبات
شمال الزهور اعطتنا نتائج اعمالها تراجع
26% باربع ربع ساعه ثالث الى اثنين فاصل
ثمانيه مليون دينار وتوصيه بتوزيع سته ثلث
همم توزيعات نقديه السهم على ثبات يعني
بتترك كيماويات على تراجع اليوم بالقطاع
المصري في لدينا تبين الوطن وبرقان على
ارتفاع الى السعوديه حيث رجعت نراها اليوم
اقوى باور بوبا اعطتنا نتائج عماله
والسهمان على تراجعات حدث يعني نكتفي بهذا
القدر الى الان اعضاء القاكم في الاسواق
العربيه بعد قليل العوده اليك ابراهيم
الان الان
رفض بعض المرشحين جمهوريين قبول نتائج
انتخابات منتصف الولايه يمهد الطريق
للفندق وقال في مقتطفات نشرها البيت
الابيض ان هناك مرشحين يتنافسون على مناصب
من كل المستويات في امريكا ولا يلتزمون
بقبول نتائج الانتخابات التي يخوضونها
واضاف بان هذا الامر يمهد الطريق الفوضى
في امريكا كما انه غير مسبوق وغير قانوني
وغير امريكي
[موسيقى]
مساله التنافس على مقاعد المشرعين في
الكونغرس كانت في السابق مقتصره على فئه
عمريه متقدمه في السن لكن
التغير بدخول ملحوظ لعنصر الشباب واقتحام
والمؤترك السياسه من اوسع الابواب
وترشح لمجلس النواب مفردات العربيه الى
ولايه فلوريدا نادر البيسي التقد بمرشحين
شابين من حزبين متنافسين في مقاطعه ميامي
باولاد فلوريدا وعكست لنا المشهد
الانتخابي في التقرير التالي
شباني في مقتبل العشرينات يريدان يضخ دماء
جديده في كونغرس يطغى عليه نواب تجاوزوا
الستينات والسبعينات في الاغلبيه
جابرييل
جونزالين لديهما اجنده مختلفه وحزبيه
بامتياز لكن هدفهما هو تغيير تركيبه مجلس
النواب الحالي
المجتمع جيدا ولدي جذور عميقه
جدايل خريج جامعه كولومبيا يريد ان يستثمر
في نسب مشاركه غير مسبوقه للشباب الذين
يقتنعون لاول مره
في المقابل يرى خصمه الجمهوري انه هموم
الناس هي نفسها هموم الشباب من تضخم
وارتفاع غير مسبوق من اسعار الوقود الى
عجز في الميزانيه سيثقل كاهل الاجيال
القادمه حيث يصل العجز الحالي الى
التريليونين و 800 مليار دولار
والاشخاص الذين قاتلوا من اجل القدوم الى
هذا البلد يفعلون ذلك بشكل قانوني
عدا عن كون المرشحين شابين فهما من اصول
لاتينيه
فبحسب مركز بيول الابحاث فعدد اللاتينيين
المسجلين للاقتراع يقدر ب 134 مليون
و500000 وهذا العدد ضم خمسه ملايين ناخد
جديد منذ الانتخابات السابقه لكن ما يقلق
الحزبين ان ثلث اللاتينيين فقط يصوطون يوم
الاقتراع واهم الولايات المتواجدين فيها
هي كاليفورنيا وتكساس وهنا في فلوريدا
ناديه البلبيسي العربيه من ما يعمل
فلوريدا
[موسيقى]
برج ايفل رمز باريس عاصمه نور منذ عقود
ومن اشهر المعالم السياحيه طالته ازمه
الطاقه في فرنسا
فالبدء في تطبيق اجراءات جديده لخط
استهلاك الطاقه اختصر مده الاضاءه الليليه
للبرج كما قال اعمده الاناره العامه في
بعض الشوارع ما اثر جدلا واسعا وصل
الفرنسيين وطرح اسئله حول السلامه
المروريه اج
راءات الطاقه كثيره الا ان مشهد اطفاء برج
ايفل لن يوما حابسه ولا من ذاكره
الفرنسيين والسياح الذين ياتون من كل صوبا
لمشاهده انوار البرج المبهره بسبب خطه
طوارئ لمواجهه ازمه الطاقه تفقد المدن
الفرنسيه شيئا فشيئا بريقها في الليل لكن
هذه الخطه بات تطرح اسئله كثيره حول
السلامه المروريه والامن مع قرار عدد من
البلديات تخفيض الاناره العامه في الشوارع
الحكومه الفرنسيه تلجا الى بعض الخطوات
منها الاطفاء الطاقه بالليل ولكن هناك
مشكله في هذا الموضوع خاصه انه يسبب
بالحوادث بالليل لذلك هذه الخطوه لا تزال
انه مؤجله او تطبق في اماكن محدده جدا
ولكن لمره بشكل كبير فاتوره الطاقه في
العاصمه وحدها نتيجه هذه الازمه تقدر ب90
مليون يورو بزياده 35 مليون يورو عن
المعتاد فاطفئت انوار بعض الشوارع وابراج
كانت يوم تضيء حي الاعمال هنا في منطقه
ومع غياب المحاسبه بعض المحالي التجاريه
والشركات لم تطبق اجراءات اطفاء الانوار
بعد الواحده ليلا فعمد نشطاء الى تولي
مهمه اطفائها من خلال جولات يقومون بها في
شوارع العاصمه سوف تلجا هذه الحكومه الى
الفرض
بقوه القانون ان تخفض الاسر وخصوصا
الشركات هذا الطلب على الطاقه سوف يتعامل
الحكومه الفرنسيه على تحديد سقوف للشركات
والمواطنين عندما تتخطى الاستهلاك هذه
الصفوف سوف يدفع المواطن عمليا
ثمن الفاتوره بسعر السوق والى ان تلتزم
الشركات بتطبيق هذه الاجراءات يخشى
المواطنون ان يدفع الجزء الاكبر من
فاتورته هذه الازمه هذه الدهوك العربيه
باريس
في نهايه مشاهده تفكيرهم بابرز عناوينها
كيف تعلن فصلا محطه زبرج النوويه عن شبكه
الكهرباء وانفجارات في مدن جنوب اوكرانيا
على وقع احتجاجات متواصله في ايران واشنطن
تسعى لطرد طهران من مجلس حقوق المراه
وتتعهد بمحاسبه النظام
ردا على التجارب الصاروخيه البيومينج
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه تمددان
مناوراتهما الجويه
وقبل ايام من انطلاقها بيدن يحذر من ان
رفض نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه للكونجرس
يمهد الطريق للفوضى
شكرا لكم على طيب متابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]